[Música]
persona la frase no de mis mujeres a
quilombos algunas personas le han
escuchado textual ahora tal vez les
suene que éramos presos muy complicadas
no podemos trabajar en equipo o mismo
que no podemos ser amigas pues siempre
va a haber algún problema o traición
somos parte del staff de revista chacha
una revista cultural feminista que nace
en junio del 2014 con el objetivo de
crear un nuevo medio de comunicación
alternativo queríamos sumar nuevas voces
pero por sobre todo queríamos nutrirnos
entre nosotras y crecer a partir de la
experiencia de otras mujeres y es a
partir de este proyecto que nos
empezamos a preguntar acaso éramos una
excepción y qué se esconde detrás del
prejuicio donde hay mujeres hay quilombo
en particular a nosotras muchas veces
les cuestionaron porque éramos solamente
un grupo formado por mujeres y porque no
había ningún varón trabajando con
nosotras cuando habla a la vez se
cuestiona en un equipo formado por
hombres la falta de mujeres además una
lectora nos contó que en su equipo de
trabajo los jefes habían puesto como
nombre al grupo de whatsapp serpentario
comparando a ella y a sus compañeras con
serpientes venenosas
si el sentido común por un lado nos dice
que las mujeres por default nos vamos a
llevar mal pero por el otro lado es muy
factible que todos conozcamos alguna
negro anécdota donde dos personas en un
ambiente de trabajo hayan tenido algún
tipo de diferencia porque solo se hace
foco en el primer caso de dónde viene
esta idea en la mayoría de los productos
culturales consumimos perpetúa la idea
de que las mujeres competimos por una
razón el varón esto no es algo que sea
solamente de las películas sino que
también se alimenta a partir de la
crianza de que somos chicas se nos educa
de tal manera que se nos coloca en la
categoría de varón o mujer que además
deja de lado todo lo que hay en el medio
por ejemplo muchas veces se asume que
por ser mujeres no estamos aptas para
asumir roles de liderazgo porque como
somos seres emocionales no estamos
capacitadas para tomar decisiones
racionales y en los casos en los que nos
mostramos seguras de nosotras mismas nos
etiquetan como mandonas cuando en un
hombre directamente sería percibido como
un líder en otros casos directamente se
nos acusa de querer parecernos
los varones lo que nos da más argumentos
a la idea de que existen ciertas esferas
sociales que están más pensadas para un
género que para el otro mientras que
existe cierta tendencia en etiquetar a
los hombres como abstractos objetivos
racionales y del ámbito público a las
mujeres se nos tiende más a catalogar
por el lado de que somos emocionales
concretas y subjetivas y del ámbito
privado
empecemos de esta vida de la
individualidad como factor histórico a
lo largo de la historia la mujer decimos
ciudad asignadas a tareas del cuidado
del hogar y otras relacionadas con el
ámbito privado entonces qué pasa cuando
salimos del ámbito privado al espacio
público
si buscamos la palabra sonoridad en el
diccionario no la vamos a encontrar de
hecho si la buscamos en un diccionario
online probablemente les aparezca este
mensaje
frente esta ausencia un grupo de
activistas feministas italianas deciden
crear este concepto con el objetivo de
nuclear la idea de unión y solidaridad
entre las mujeres para crear lazos que
promuevan nuestros derechos ahora el
lenguaje es una construcción social que
va evolucionando con el tiempo y que la
palabra sonoridad no está
institucionalizada no nos impide poder
usarla pero sí refleja como el discurso
dominante tiende a invisibilizar los
lazos entre las mujeres
pensémoslo así el lenguaje expresa el
orden simbólico de la ley social que
rige una cultura y si no se nombra la
palabra es como si no existiese
y entre mujeres llevo mucho tiempo para
llegar a dónde estamos ahora pasaron las
casas de brujas las sufragistas y hoy
nos encontramos acá con nuestros
recursos nosotros quedamos trocha y en
paralelo surgió el movimiento en una
menos y otros movimientos mundiales que
están cambiando el mundo entonces
claramente con la mujer y nos unimos
pasan cosas muy buenas
además se aprende un montón porque no se
nace feminista se hace
pasaron cuatro años y nuestro proyecto
de revista llega a su fin más que
nada porque el haber trabajo entre
nosotras nos dio las herramientas como
para poder liderar nuestros propios
proyectos personales pero si hay algo
que aprendimos por sobre todo es que
logramos construir un espacio donde nos
sintiésemos seguras entre nosotras
aprendimos que nuestras experiencias
como mujeres no eran casos aislados sino
lo que sino que lo que nos pasábamos a
una le podía pasar a la otra por ejemplo
que un hombre haga uso y abuso de su
privilegio y que comenté sobre nuestro
cuerpo en la calle ya no se puede
esconder detrás del falso piropo sino
que ahora hablamos de acoso callejero y
logramos erradicar el término crimen
pasional cuando estamos hablando de
femicidios
ya las feministas décadas atrás nos lo
habían enseñado lo personal es político
en la unión entre mujeres nosotros
logramos alentarnos entre nosotras nos
atrevemos a decir yo también y
entendimos que no estábamos solas
sin embargo pensar que las mujeres no
hacemos que llegar bien solo por el
hecho de ser mujeres es una ironía
tenemos nuestras diferencias nos
limitamos a mi nombre de ser mejores
amigas gobiernos pensar de esta manera
cree una imagen polarizante y erosiona
las complejidades que tenemos como
sujetos venimos de distintas culturas
somos distintos tamaños colores de piel
algunas tenemos útero y otras no hay una
densidad ser madres y otras no podemos
estar en pareja con mujeres varones o
cualquier otra identidad de género
abracemos nuestras diferencias porque es
ahí donde se crean equipos plurales y
dinámicos nos han creado la
individualidad y al mismo tiempo creemos
en mujeres fuertes e independientes
independientes de que los hombres nos
digan que tenemos que hacer
sí pero no independientes entre nosotras
abraza tu amiga a tu hermana a la
desconocida de boliche y a la compañera
que tienes al lado volvamos a construir
o descubramos el pacto implícito que hay
entre nosotras porque nadie los puede
conocer mejor
tu historia puede ser parecida a la de
otra y así creamos una cadena de
sonoridad que es la frase eslabón se va
haciendo cada día más fuerte cuando se
crea un grupo de trabajo entre mujeres
se crea un nuevo sabor y tenemos que
probarlo
trabajar entre mujeres y lograr
construir algo juntas nos dio las
herramientas para poder desestigmatizar
la frase donde hay mujeres hay quilombo
queremos armar quilombo porque no nos
queremos quedar más en un segundo plano
ya no nos callamos más para nosotras
donde hay mujeres hay revolución
[Aplausos]
[Música]